[Music]
we're gonna have a small room tonight
and
ladies question based on what we've
talked about many times in the past so
welcome to the 26th session in the
worlds of speculative fiction we're both
old hands at this so I don't have to say
what we're gonna do
we'll talk a little bit about the
biography of camp and then jump into
world building and some philosophical
themes I had five that I thought were
kind of interesting in terms of these
particular novels and what we're talking
about with L Sprague de Kamp is a
complete enchanter actually we should
have the complete complete enchanter
which has all five stories but this is
the one that I can get my hands on here
and the Milwaukee area and it's kind of
a misnomer because if these are written
with Fletcher Pratt we'll talk about a
bit as well I first read these myself
only about in the last ten years there
was I'd read a lot of Sprague de Kamp in
other contexts but I'd never read these
and when we were still in Kingston I
found the complete completed chanter
though that's that looks kind of
interesting I was poking through the
sci-fi stuff and so I started reading it
I was like wow this is really great
stuff well-written very imaginative and
extremely funny so I thought that it
would make a good you know set of things
to talk about in part because there is a
it's nothing you know settled at once in
the world but it isn't a coherent
narrative universe all held together by
this this notion of symbolic logic of
all things which could never work the
way things were going is that thing
right but we'll talk about that
in event but I thought it was such a fun
series that it would be good to do for
for this
he's been very influential and he's had
connections with quite a few of the
people who we've been looking at he
actually worked in the Philadelphia
Naval Yard with Asimov and Heinlein for
for a while during World War Two they
were there a number of these guys who
wound up contributing to the war effort
not as combatants but you know they they
put their brains to work a scientist
yeah exactly yeah so you want to should
we go over the timeline for so you know
he's born in 1907 dies in 2000 so a very
long life and he's you know the owl is
is lying that's you know he was named
after he's born in New York City and
then eventually he gets he gets sent as
a kid to this Snyder School in North
Carolina it was not a real fan of it but
you know he went there and then he
starts going to count
Kaltag right California Institute of
Technology and he you know like a lot of
these people that were studying in this
time he earns degrees in technical
fields that require a lot of mathematics
I think you know the training at that
time probably would have been in certain
respects more similar to what we do in
the humanities although there would have
been an intensive being a math and
science component not like you know what
a lot of our kids are learning today
where they just get shut put off on
their own track and they they don't do
very much of that and he he ends up you
know running a bachelor's in science and
aeronautical engineering that's quite an
accomplishment earns his master's and
engineering starts working doing patent
stuff which you know rather dull but he
the bills and you notice this isn't a
middle of depression so you know any
work is good and he starts publishing in
in 1937 so he's thirty years old and you
know Paul work these all showed up in
pulps as well and then he gets fired
from from editing this this trade
journal that he said well that was
actually a good thing for good because
then I could start focusing on really
writing he marries this woman Catherine
crook who would would also work as his
rewrite editor and sometimes
collaborator during the rest of their
years together and he he meets Fletcher
Pratt and becomes major collaborator as
a matter of fact the reason why Fletcher
Pratt's going to die you know in 1956
and there were plans to write more of
these novels and you know they they had
some things already plotted out it just
really wasn't possible for Alf Sprague
de Kamp to pull off what he was doing
without regret he tried writing some
stuff with some other guys but it just
never it never came out right and you
notice now he's starting to you know
write more and more stuff the incomplete
and enchanter comes out and that
includes I've got this on this chart
here the first two big stories the
roaring trumpet and the mathematics of
magic and so those are both from 1940
and so you've got kind of a thin volume
but it gives you enough of what's going
on in the universe for people to have an
idea about it and then the the third
story is published in 1941 and the the
complete enchanter is going to come out
bit later on and then later on they'll
have the complete completed
which which has the the fourth and fifth
story in it but you notice he's writing
a lot of stuff throughout the the 40s
and 50s
you know one year he's extremely
prolific 1953 he's also writing a lot of
other stuff that I didn't put in there
he writes non-fiction works
he was quite active and you know you
could say kind of bringing bringing to
the masses you know what what sign you
know the sort of stuff that would add in
popular science for example or Popular
Mechanics that whole sort of culture of
listen you know the the world is
complicated but science can help us
understand it he was he was very
involved with that and he starts winning
some some awards 1953 was an
international Fantasy Award for non
fiction it brings out a writing guide
that science fiction handbooks he's he's
clearly somebody who's thinking about
not just how to write stories but about
the craft itself which which i think is
kind of interesting and you know he's
involved in that saga group this
swordsman and Sorcerer's Guild of
America I can't find out maybe you know
well I can't find out when it was
actually founded people list different
dates there is somewhere between 61 and
65 so I put 63 thought this you know but
then you know it shows you who he's
connected with and even right so the
thing later on literary swordsmen and
sorcerers about the group so that's in
76 about maybe 15 years later he also
has a biography of Lovecraft in there
which I haven't read but I'm looking
forward to getting to read sometime and
that sounds quite interesting and you
know you see that again I didn't put all
of his works in here he's not writing an
awful lot of fiction
later on he's right
more science fiction but he does some
interesting things you know he gets some
awards they moved to Texas they travel
to Easter Island and you know he his
life is is fairly straightforward and
sedate in many ways I did have a few
things that got talked about by other
people for example george RR martin
right george RR martin who we looked at
a couple years ago said when i was a kid
in grade school of dreamed of telling
stories they found owl Sprague de Kamp's
science fiction handbook even the bayon
public library his how-to book inspired
me so much i would take it out every few
months and read it all over again and he
looked at sections of it he is providing
sort of like a here's how to actually do
the the craft which which is kind of
kind of interesting he also did have a
bit of a time editing conan novels like
uma and the adventure was in here yeah
well he intensive Conan he wrote some
stuff himself and he was he was hired to
edit the stuff but he rewrote type
scripts and that he censored some some
parts he wrote rewrote Howard story is
adding new characters and sometimes he
you know modified it considerably so
we're gonna talk about this when we get
to Howard we're gonna do later on I
think this summer how much of Howard is
actually Howard and how much of it is
other people he also did meet Tolkien at
one point there's the remember coming
across this he said we sat in the garage
for a couple of hours smoking pipes
drinking beer and talking about it
things practically anything the English
literature from Beowulf down
Tolkien had read and Katoch
intelligently about he indicated he
rather liked Howard's Conan stories Oh
quite quite interesting there and I
don't think there's that much more to
say in terms of biography you know
there's a lot more to say about this
this world that he's creating so you
know I it's not a world it's it's a
whole set of worlds sort of like what
would uh you know what Louis did with
the Magician's Nephew
where you've got this this juncture
point where you can get out of this
world and then you can go into all these
other worlds and and you know Louis has
his characters explore a few of those
that's something similar to what's going
on here except it begins in this world
and the the they have out there having
like a conversation where they they
reveal how things are going to come out
you know and it's a conversation between
the very smart scientists although
they're all psychologists and you know
the brash guy who's a little bit of an
over compensator who's gonna be the main
hero the Harold Shea of The Herald chase
stories and they're going back and forth
about you know could other worlds exist
and so you know in the end these novels
they they call it pair of physics you
know the physics beyond the physics that
we have and the way in which you would
get yourself into another world is by
using symbolic logic so we'll talk a
little bit more about how that's
supposed to work which couldn't possibly
work like that but it's an interesting
plot device and it's basically you know
connected with this this notion that we
see coming up over and over again and
philosophy
that the world that we're experiencing
right now is in large part a construct
of how we're projecting order out to the
world so you and I are sharing this this
room here and you know it might actually
look very different to you than it does
to me but I don't know that until you
start talking about or behaving in the
room and even then I'm probably going to
keep on believing that you're proceeding
in exactly the same way because we like
regularity but but you know maybe all of
this is just you know sort of jamesy and
booming buzzing confusion that were
projecting these these categories on to
that we're just used to or this is the
way our minds have to work but it could
be read in very different ways so you
know think about somebody coming from
Norse mythology which is the first place
where they go to there you've got a
world where people perceive things in
very different ways and most importantly
magic works you know in our world magic
doesn't work
barri I mean we've got magicians who do
tricks but we don't we we think that
magic itself is not something you know
lurking in the background in this world
and and they're perfectly happy with
that but in the other worlds magic
wouldn't work and so you know you all
you have to do is think yourself into a
different set of rules use what would
Harold Shay calls a syllogism 'mobile
you know a argument essentially that
would be like a big construct of all the
rules of that world and you're suddenly
in that world and you're experiencing it
so you know like the first one it's the
world of Norse mythology he's actually
trying to get into the Irish mythology
world because he wants to hang out with
my Arish girls and it doesn't work it's
like some stuck with these Norse gods
leading up to Ragnarok
then in the second one its Edmund
Spenser's The Faerie Queene and they you
know they actually get themselves into
the the story or the land of the story
rather no not the story so much because
the story is more linear right and and
if you think about how this is supposed
to work it's sort of like I guess it's
sort of like what people really like
about video games you know like if you
have a you know the Lord of the Rings
for example and that's a linear story
and there's a lot of you know
digressions here and there and you know
unfinished parts sometimes but you know
more or less as a beginning middle of
that all right but if you're in a game
that's just populated with you know
there's works over there and I was over
there and you can pick out anything you
want to get to work do you want to be in
a half-elf you want to be this or that
there's a lot more scope for for play
again I guess that you know sort of like
what people were really getting into is
role-playing games to you know so I mean
that's what because look what becomes
possible within these these worlds is an
exploration of it in the third one
there's a brief interlude where they
they wind up in the Coleridge's Kubla
Khan for a brief bit and realize they'd
better get the hell out of there because
it's an unfinished poem and you know
they're going to be in trouble so they
go into Aristo Orlando Furioso the world
of that as well and then they finally
get into other worlds in the later
stories the world of the Kalevala the
Finnish national epic and then finally
the world of Irish mythology and each
one has got its own little construct
each one has its the way things work in
there you know so the magicians do
things differently from from world to
world although there are similarities so
so you know in the theory anything that
we could imagine there's going to be
some actual world out there that
corresponds to it so you know all the
things that we've been discussing in
these sessions every single one of them
I guess you know if you could think you
the multiverse yeah I mean it is a
multiverse and the way that Chalmers
talks about it is that all these places
do exist within the same space the space
that we're occupying right now but they
they are at sort of the he describes it
as I have right angles with each other
which is not particularly helpful I
think it's trying to visualize it but he
also says anything that a poet or
fictional author is picturing to
themselves is actually like it's
connected in some way to to the world so
if you start writing a novel and you're
exercising your imagination and I don't
know you you know what what's your novel
going to look like you know maybe you
know we're talking about people having
psionic powers and things like that
there have to be certain rules for that
and then you start doing the
world-building part you know who's going
to be in charge are there conflicts you
know what's what's the geography like
well as soon as you start imagining that
your imagination is actually syncing up
with something that is out there that
does exist and you can move from world
to world so I mean you can see a lot of
possibility for abuse thank you but you
know you can see a lot of other
interesting possibilities as well well
it sounds like relates to the Irish
Irish mythology the concept of the
thinnest spaces well tell me about that
because I don't know that in Celtic
mythology the idea is that twice a year
Beltane and sewing okay
the the space between this world and the
next
becomes a in place or destinies and it's
easier to cross but is that just for
like the like the land of the living in
the land of the dead was the land of the
living in the land of anything else
something else okay yeah it's not
necessarily the dead okay it's something
more metaphysical warm oh you know
spirits or you know it could be look you
you could call it the land of the dead
mm-hmm but it could also be another
dimension of existence when the thin
space happens but something that's more
essential something that's more in some
ways more real but it's like the land of
fairy okay it's the difference between
here and the land of fairy yeah because
that the other side is where the the
hunting god the hunter comes from and
the queen of fairy yeah and so it's that
the concept that couple times a year
crossing is easier yeah yes it can be
crossed and other times in the year but
the thin space has happened a couple of
times a year where crossing is much
easier and if you can cross accidentally
if you're not careful yeah so what
happens in this is it's not based on
time it's based on the actions of the
people involved there's two ways that
people wind up moving between worlds one
is through like I mean literally putting
together reams of paper with with
formulas on
where it's supposed to represent the the
world that you're trying to get into
that's how they first do it and then
once somebody is in the other world and
they understand what they're doing they
can put a like a call that sucks other
people from this world in to use an app
to that one which is what happens with
Chalmers bringing Shae and this is them
the check
[Music]
václav pull up pull a check the rubber
check that column on into the other
world longer the police officer who was
trained to to arrest them who's never
been happy about being stuck there
but yeah so so it's almost like you
generate the thinness right there's a
formula generated in this yeah and so
now here we started this is a good
jumping-off point to talk about is some
of this stuff actually coherent or not
so you got a multiverse and it's got all
these different settings and people in
it and what's most important the way
that these characters represent it is
the sort of fundamental laws under
girding and that tell you how that world
works
so I mean this actually does make a lot
of sense say with like computer
simulations where the computer
simulation really is defined primarily
by the laws that say how say gravity
works or you know how if you shoot a
projectile and somebody do they have hit
points that you take away or things like
that I don't know that that it works so
well with with entire worlds if we're
saying that these are also real worlds
are not and and they're you know the
other thing that goes along with this
too is there would be no single like
central point that would be you know
like the for the characters there is a
central point early but every one of
these worlds would be just as real as
the others so the world of Norse
mythology
is just as real as the world of the
fairy queen just as real as the world
that whirring just as real as some
sci-fi universe you know I'd say the
Star Trek universe right
what you're talking I think about is
there's a series of books by Ted
Williams called the other land students
and in that world is created
mathematically through a virtual reality
a new system so it exists in a world
though already right in which the
virtual reality is sighted there's
there's this world yeah and then the
connection through virtual reality to
other land yeah and other land actually
becomes real now real in what sense
that's that occur right people are kids
are drawn into it mentally by the
connection to the VR yeah but if they
died another land if they dot here okay
and it's a very long plotline but its
multiple worlds either way it is
multiple worlds they cross over because
the game the gaming systems have
different bullets so within other other
land system there's multiple worlds yeah
in that case though each of the multiple
worlds is still sort of like a what's
called a local world within a larger
unified system they're created
mathematically and logically by creating
the virtual reality system yeah
so in this I mean we don't get many
examples other than like a little bit of
sort of logical it's actually it's kind
of GABA we look at the beginning of each
of these where this here's an example
and the very first one there roaring
trumpet him Harold che is he's got him
so setup so it was actually kind of good
to talk about he says he he got himself
a flashlight a gun with plenty of
ammunition
hunting knife you know box of matches a
Gaelic dictionary thinks he's going to
Ireland and the Boy Scout Handbook and
he's got all this stuff set up with him
and then he starts writing logical
equations and this is the stuff that
we're used to from like symbolic logic
classes you know so here's how how it
how it reads he says if P equals not Q Q
implies not P which is equivalent to
saying either P or Q or neither but not
both but if not P is not implied by not
Q the counter implicate a form of the
proposition and then it like you know
goes on and off and then he starts you
know going into other more complex stuff
the full argument thus consistent in
Epicure Matt Caramanica syllogism and
Barbara the major premise of which is
not the conclusion of an enthymeme
though the Viner premise of which may
not be the conclusion of an honor
resilience or he tastes you know now so
here when you're reading that you're
like well this this is actually nonsense
you know he's not I mean whatever he is
saying this could not be the
representation of the world so we have
to do you know do some what do you call
the suspension of disbelief right in
order to make it work
I mean but if we think about it in a
larger sense so he does bring up okay a
little bit earlier when they're they're
going back and forth because this is a
smart way of introducing the whole you
know premise that gets them going with
pair of physics
Chalmers says here we go if one of these
infinite other worlds which up to now
may be said to exist an illogical but
not an empirical sense is governed by
magic you might expect to find a
principle like that of dependence
invalid the logical thing in our room
but principles of magic such as the law
of similarity valid is Beinart says our
Bayer and says what's the law of
similarity effects resemble causes it's
not valid for us but primitive people's
firmly believe it for instance they
think you can make it rain by pouring
water on the ground with appropriate
mumbo-jumbo and Shay says I didn't I
didn't know you could have
principles of magic and Chalmer says
certainly medicine men don't merely go
through hocus-pocus they believe they're
working through natural laws so in a
world where everybody firmly believed in
these laws here we get some of the
metaphysics that is one where all minds
were attuned to receive the proper
impressions the laws of magic would
conceivably work as one years of witch
doctor spells working in Africa today
Frasier's or the Golden Bough guy right
at Seabrook I don't actually know have
worked out some of these magical laws
and others the law of contagion things
once and content continued to interact
from a distance after separation and so
what he's laying out our you know what
what could be produced as a sort of an
exhaustive listing of these these laws
but notice what he's done there he's
referred to stuff in this world people
who in this world believe this stuff
actually works now why would they have
those those beliefs in our world where
we say well science and symbolic logic
rules those people are just primitive or
they're deluded or something like that
but there is a world corresponding to
them where their beliefs would would be
the normal and everybody in it so if we
think about he's using you know like
people who are considered primitive at
that time you know maybe indigenous
tribes but if we think back to the
examples that he was using like Norse
mythology and believing in the magic and
the it's column like the the structure
of the divine that the
of that time where the gods themselves
aren't really that godlike maker specs
you know they can get killed they you
know they can be beaten up by Giants
there's all sorts of problems they can
get tricked by magic themselves you
could represent that in some way you
could like lay out what the rules are
and then by by thinking yourself into
those rules you would thereby place
yourself in that that space and so the
question is people in this world you
know were the people the Norse at the
time that they believed there was going
to be a Ragnarok and they believed in
Odin and Thor were they somehow
participating in that that world is not
an imaginary world then but a real world
and just didn't didn't realize it you
know is the process of civilization
maybe like a sort of homogeneous Asian
of this world that we're in a state
where they talk about you know
disenchantment taking all the magic out
of the world the way people complain
that the modern era is one where we
turned everything into the knowable took
away the magic yeah I mean he's not
saying that here but that would seem to
be part of the background metaphysics of
it well it strikes me and you know
Philip or offices works no he's got two
books out we're still waiting for the
third but it's arcane knowledge its
alchemy okay it's tied with the alchemy
not so much magic people receive it as
magic yeah because it's so different
yeah but it's alchemy and there's a
school arcane knowledge other so there's
there's a method there's a method to it
and part of the method when you talk
about connection yeah part of the method
in the teachings you have to have a
strong mental belief in what's going to
happen if you don't it doesn't happen
see now that brings up a really interest
so that mental yeah you have it in your
head you have to believe that this works
yeah that's not something that was
actually thinking about is the theme
that that actually is a good theme so
the characters the characters who are at
like existent fairyland right like the
Falco who's going to become the wife of
Shay a little bit later on she grew up
in there her mind works according to
both of those laws of fairyland and
she's never known anything different so
it's not a problem for her but the
people like like Shay and Chalmers who
get themselves into fairyland in order
to get themselves there they have to
convince themselves of this this way of
looking at things they have to adopt a
completely different perspective than
what they're used to and yet in order to
be able to have not lose themselves in
it and still have kind of let's call it
a critical perspective because that
would be the technical term for it or
they can be bigoted engage in judgment
they couldn't completely buy into it all
right so they're they're caught I mean
how do they do that do they oscillate
back and forth do they look at it both
ways at the same time do they have like
a higher perspective where they are
they're choosing between perspectives
you know this is one of the this is one
of the difficulties in position believe
it enough to exist but not to operate
the magic
well they do operate the magnetic and
that's the interesting part and it takes
them a while to figure out precisely how
to do it there's a learning curve you
could say right and it turns out that
Chalmers is way better at it than
Shane's Chalmers is this kind of
you know bookish type he's older he's
the the sort of fatherly figure but he
falls in love with with somebody else in
the other world - well a learning curve
would make sense if you think of it in
terms of you believe enough to make the
transition yeah and then the more you
believe the more able you are to do the
magic so that the belief is something
the belief gets you there the initial
belief right but it's kind of a weak
belief right yeah and this more strongly
you believe it or strongly believe that
learning curve from using the magic
increases so instead of another model
would be that you like just have to
believe a certain amount of stuff and
then you get better by believing yet
more stuff right don't make sense role
model well maybe you'd have to have both
them maybe you'd have to have like you
you have just that all the lines the the
bear like you know how the world works
but you don't really know the details of
it you know like I mean there they go
through a lot of funny stuff we're like
they're trying to do this spell and it
doesn't work out quite the way that they
want and you know instead of getting one
thing they get a thousand things of this
sort you know then it all has to be done
with with the language oh that was
another theme so I don't attack them so
so symbolic logic right it's easy to see
why at the time that they wrote these
people would have been been able to use
that that's kind of a workable trumpet
because on the one hand philosophy was
making some advances in in symbolic
logic and a lot of those advances were
merely just being able to symbolize
things and then operate on them and
you know like put them back in ordinary
language again they were fascinated with
that during the time that these guys are
are writing and similar things are
happening because philosophy was
communicating at that time with
mathematics and with physics and and all
these sorts of things so it makes sense
that somebody who's smart like these
guys are would be talking about hey to
Lenin and and so you know but the issue
is can you really represent the world
through the rules by which the world
works through symbolic logic and I don't
think that you really can with with the
kind of symbolic logic that they're
using maybe there is another you know
more developed one where the idea of
symbolic logic to define our world was
its user a couple things even using it
yeah you know even in within our
constructs yeah our our reality it's
it's designed to describe behavior and
the laws particular interaction it's
supposed to let us do more than that
it's Uranus it's intended to symbolize
but it's intended to symbolize so that
we in some way we can operate on it and
we can we can judge the true from the
false we can you know we can arrive at
decisions it's very tough to do and
we're in practice defining true from the
false yeah defining the world yeah I
think it's that's right
I have to find the world yeah I had to
take symbolic logic because I started
out at math major
oh yeah but it's I always saw it as
another way to define the world to
define the winners of the world and you
know that actually was one of the goals
behind the people who were making the
big advances in symbolic logic was they
they thought they would have be able to
apply it to everything
now there's there's another wrinkle -
which is we can talk about modal logic
as well and they didn't have access to
that at the time modal logic deals with
necessity possibility impossibility
these sorts of things and so it adds new
symbolism in there that we can then you
know say this is you know if this is
possible then this is necessary or
things like that now the reason I bring
it up is because in I think the front
like the the 70s 80s and 90s I might be
as taking the time of it it might have
happened in the eighties they started
using this modal logic to talk about
possible worlds which is exactly what
these stories are about right possible
worlds and the idea was that you
wouldn't use logic to define what the
world was instead the logic would like
carry across all possible worlds these
guys the logic doesn't carry across all
the possible worlds each world has its
own peculiar logic right San Francisco
yeah yeah absolutely
I was I was struggling to understand the
beginning of the book yeah so the
syllogism Oh Beall yes yeah so like I
know what he was doing like the effects
and like he was doing a bunch of stuff
like that like so does he just go one by
one until like something snaps and then
he's transported somewhere
I did yes so then I mean that's that's
the beauty of writing fiction right you
can telescope all this stuff in because
it you know to begin with if he was
going to give us like a full list he
would occupy a lot of pages and I don't
know if these two guys Pratt and Alice
break the camp could have actually come
up with it you know what what is like
the complete outline for the
pretty well yeah for Irish mythology or
or Norse mythology you know I mean they
just like write it down on a piece of
paper and then plug it in like a black
box and then they write it down on the
piece of paper and then they read
through it themselves to put themselves
in the mental framework of believing
that that's really the case that that's
that's the way the world is so imagine
like I mean here's a silly example so so
because there reflects it within your
own mind your transport exactly yeah
yeah no I mean a silly example this
would be the guy who told you that
you know every morning get in front of
the mirror and say every day in every
way I'm getting better and better and
better
right so people actually did this in the
70s in the 80s and I didn't even make
these before label yeah yeah well I mean
there was even a great like SNL spoof
that Phil Harkin used to do and it was
those work for some people but I don't
know that it works that long I mean you
feel a little bit better if you walk
around and you're in can't change the
world it's not the crappy world the less
now it's a world where you can get by
but then you meet your first like
obstacle and that whole like I don't
mind stuff that you put yourself in
falls apart these guys are doing
something that allows them to be in that
world and then no longer have to keep
looking about yeah they don't have to
they don't have to maintain that they've
shifted in a certain way how the hell
that happens you know could we do that
that's that's part of what we have been
talking about I don't think so I don't
think that's I think that he's talking
about a very interesting imaginative
possibility that you know when we think
it through it's just not coherent
but it's great fiction it's really well
written I'm surprised yeah yeah actually
one of the critics that said there's
there's parts of it that don't hold
together but it's great screwball
fantasy screwball is like you know Mel
Brooks and things like that where
you know it's very funny but if you if
you poke at it too much it doesn't
really hold together you know but I
don't think they they they even really
meant it to do so yeah so you know the
language occupies a kind of weird place
in that's right because you have to
symbolise things through language and
then all the magic is done through
language to some degree but can you
really represent or act upon the world
through language in the way that their
door they're portraying it notice too
that they're not logicians they're all
psychiatrists or psychologists you know
which one Baird maybe the older guy well
Chalmers yeah Chalmers he's a
psychologist - yes he's he's running
their Institute whirring say well I was
thinking the time within chiming within
which this was written these were
written mostly is the same timeframe
within which a merit was writing his
various worlds he wrote a number of
books about different worlds and
nightlife of the Gods was written at
that time which is very screwy very
madcap kind of thing yeah all of which
require pretty major suspension of
disbelief you know they're they're
possible but I don't know exactly the
word we're looking for there is more
it's not it's it's it's not just a
question of whether it's possible it's
got to be made plausible right yeah
that's the moment just so we have two
different modalities there and how does
how does the writing manage to do that I
mean we could say it tricks us in a way
right precisely then when you ask
questions like well how exactly is this
supposed to work how's this supposed to
translate it
own experience that's when we start to
see you know if we're gay is another
metaphor we start to see like it's
there's what there's a stage and it's
actually a bunch of what do they call
that props but the the scenery the you
know it's not a real background that we
can look into it's just a painted
background there's actually a great
expression painted now only a painted
coat can be hung you know but you can't
hang a painted coat on it it's just that
you're stuck within that that frame
there was another book actually that the
camp wrote early on where he's doing
alternative history was called les
darkness fall and it's it's a similar to
Connecticut Yankee in King Arthur's
Court
this guy's visiting the Pantheon he
finds himself transported in Rome in the
year 535 ad and I put a note in here
about that because again it's a play
with the same idea like being in a
different setting you know although
they're it's just going back in time
with this you're actually in a different
world right well this in this you've got
both aspects really because north to
south
yes mythology Celtic mythology happens
at a different timeframe in history yeah
the earlier civilization I'm about
halfway through and I remember like a
few pages before they were talking about
how like oh wait if we go back it'll be
like the 25th century or something oh
there's a discussion in there about do
you write about
this is traumas just carrying out and
saying so you know imagine these things
of being at right angles to each other
he's using pencils to represent them he
says this is why I like in Fairyland
somebody's in Fairyland for
and then he shows up much later you know
like a couple years in the past so
they're there they're worried about
those that you see that in all sorts of
works
oh yeah works like that the one of the
standard laws of the land of fairy is
when you enter the land of fairy a lot
more time passes on the outside and on
the inside people who go into the land
of fairy when they come out it is a much
later sea in there you're talking about
the relation between the two wheels
right what's what's the time ratio and
so it's not just what are the laws of
this world you could say some of the
laws of fairy are laws that pertain just
to that world but then that one would be
a law that has to do the bridge between
the worlds right well are just the law
within the land of fairy is that time
moves in a different rate what only
moves at a different rate in relation
relationship yeah in the land of fairy
and all that so that's still moving at
the same rate so so it's locally correct
let's say or locally I don't know
continuous no that's not the right word
either because it's all continuous
locally consistent and then when you
when you go back to the other world
there's kind of a jarring effect and
that brings up the problem too you know
you know it sounds almost like I'm
complaining about that event and all the
case I just you know trying to think
about how this would work that I really
enjoy them myself but you have these uh
these love relationships across the
worlds right people can follow them
along with each other which I guess
makes sense you're gonna go to somebody
else's country you know I can fall in
love with them and then either I become
a resident there or I bring them over
here and we get a green card or
something like that and and that's
happening with with in the very first
one oh no I'm sorry in the second one
the fell guy comes across too
the earth - that's real and she's in
love with with Shay and Chalmers also
has this this woman who has made of snow
for a long time and I can't remember her
name
you haven't gotten that far into a
necklace yeah okay yeah but he isn't
he's trying to figure out how he can
keep her from from melting he doesn't
succeed even with converting therefore
he does eventually okay yeah but now the
real question is so they they move out
of their world that to this world how
are they able to make that transition
you know this is just somebody pulling
them along by the hand they're they're
not using the syllogism 'mobile you know
and then you know when they're in love
with somebody is a lot of the sort of
thing that comes like overcome whatever
sort of world systems were in so we if
you're in love with somebody in in this
in one world you're in love with them
within all possible worlds perhaps you
know it's the magic that's been in this
thing
well in terms of a person who's come
from this world into another life yeah
you already have in your head the logic
of this world
yes the reality of this world so it's a
matter of remembering maybe well the
it's not a problem it's not right it's
not problem for that yeah it's how do
you get
butthere's lumber how do you get your
over here whoever yeah across yeah and
and there is it that reminds me there's
also a thing of their tour but fell gets
forgotten who she is and then she's in
love with him as well now reawakening
that I mean it seems like that that love
that has to be some sort of constant
that survives across world shifts right
so whatever whatever logic you have
driving this world and in this world of
this world lung has to work the same way
in all the worlds do you ever watch this
show that's a long time I've watched a
few episodes yeah but because there's a
washer there's a construct in that
series where you have multiple roles
okay there's the world of Wonderland
there's the world you know Alice in
Wonderland yeah but when people cross
worlds in some cases they don't remember
who they are
well but yeah but the connection the
love connections the emotional
connection the emotional connection
still exist if they find each other okay
so as they when they cross into a world
of no magic this one this world they
have different identities different you
know living situations professions etc
but the love connection still exists so
when does it apply just to love or does
it also say applied to hate it applies
to all of that applies to all that so
for example when Cinderella and Prince
Charming
that's a rock I mean Snow White and
Prince Charming finally connect yeah
it's the connection still exists so that
would imply that in a certain way our
emotional attachments and responses
again span span across different logics
you know maybe they fell outside of it
it's consciously they don't know that
they're those two people or two
characters but the love the emotion
continues to be there okay so they that
plays out in the different worlds within
the once-upon-a-time multiverse mmm as
people move across words yeah I mean
that does sound very similar to what's
going on here I think there's a lot of
across a lot of these altars actual well
when you talk about developing
multiverses yeah I think there seem to
be some pretty standard Oh like tropes
that they all yeah
rules in terms of how these things
unfold there's some differences yeah I
mean there's gonna be some because
there's that creative aspect if they're
doing they're all gonna put their own
there's a different spin on it yeah but
there's some real similarities when
you're talking about anybody's writing
the multiverse yeah there seem to be
some real similarities now whether
that's because you know it has to work
that way or they're inspired a certain
way or they're influenced by other
influenced by the other people I mean
when I do like about this and you might
be able to say something more about this
too is they are the campin and print are
trying to be as consistent as possible
about how the magic actually works like
a sort of technology you know the you
know the rules once learned you can
actually apply them and the spells that
they they have Shea and then Chalmers do
later they they do make sense within
that framework you know even though the
mistakes make sense and they provide
explanations and why the mistakes turn
out the things that they do right so
that's kind of fun you know and think
about why that's fun is it that just we
like some sort of order you know that
makes sense even though it's a totally
imaginative order you know maybe it's
the best way that the author can
construct something that would be like
understandable to the individual
otherwise it's like you can't comprehend
it it's hard to committee has to make
sense if it was too experimental you
could say I think then nobody would buy
it in these pulp magazines right maybe I
didn't even notice is written in 1940
yeah yeah they were they were originally
in pulp magazines and I've known and
then later on and yeah fantasy fiction
of beyond fantasy fiction so you know
that was a audience that would they were
they be familiar with a lot of sort of
tropes but they would not be willing to
let you be so experimental that they
have no idea what the hell you're
talking about
so yeah yes be able to relate to it or
else
well again so they liked the emotional
stuff you know you've got you've got
these characters who are quite
compelling you know Harold Shea the very
first story is him and he's a little bit
too overconfident because he's
compensating for stuff he's you never
really settles down to work on a project
the way a good you know clinician would
and he's thrown into the world of Norse
mythology has a rough time at first and
then gets his bearings and he comes out
of it and he's a changed man at the
beginning of the second novel and you
know he's very know he has real
confidence and that's what convinces
Chalmers that it actually works that
he's like well you know people don't
change in personality over just a you
know a day or two clearly you've been
gone for quite a while and have gone
through some stuff and that he's that
he's that way the rest of the time and
it's also fun that they make room for
the other characters the first one is
just you know Harold Shayne and the
other characters you know Heimdall and
Odin and Thor those types but then
Chalmers you know has has his role the
the check guy václav begins to play an
important
you know each of them get throughout and
the women characters - flora Mel and
Belle [ __ ] you know so another thing I
wanted to talk about was this idea of
magic as technology is that is that the
best way to understand it you're I mean
you're talking about alchemy before
mm-hmm you know there's there's another
book out and I don't remember the guys
name but he is from here in Wisconsin
he's over in Madison
he just wants some sort of a board yeah
their office is it these boys the guy
who talks about the flight these these
are these are people who are carrying
out magic but they call it empirical
philosophy yeah this is very recent it's
somebody else and it works by you know
doing the sort of things that magic does
using certain powders and glyphs and all
that but it's it's being understood as
philosophy philosophy that actually does
it does work and in it it's sort of like
well women are better at it the witches
are better than the warlocks and men
don't really do flight much and of
course the hero's a guy and yes yes but
I like the idea of it being experimental
philosophy in the sense of well you know
you try out these things and if you're
in the right kind of environment well
doing this thing produces this result
right putting these powders together
with this formula and doing it at maybe
at this right time for yourselves
yeah and it does it according to certain
laws so magic becomes sort of like a
substitute for technology there it's
it's like the opposite of the
Connecticut
King Arthur's Court though right Mark
Twain the Connecticut Yankee goes back
in time and he like sets up batteries
and Electrify his knights and everyone's
like wow this guy is such a great
magician you know but he's really just
using technology exactly yeah
so now I raise alchemy how come he's the
same kind of thing if you put these
things together and show you this sort
of result this result to make gold you
do these things and say you can get
going yeah to make a ruby you do these
things and you laughing cuz I'm thinking
back to my high school chemistry class
which is which is terrible
quite quite honestly it was an honors
chemistry class so you know we have that
graph paper the you know to write lab
reports so we would do all these
experiments and invariably about half
the class the experiments have failed
now what is the purpose of a chemistry
experiments not just to keep the kids
busy for an hour
you're supposed to be demonstrating to
them that science really works the way
that we say that it works right doing so
experientially and if an experiment is a
real experiment and it doesn't go the
way you're you're saying it's supposed
to go you're supposed to derive some
results like well maybe when you put
these things together this doesn't
actually work this way and the
scientific you know reasoning there's
something wrong with it we never did
that we would have the instructor would
go to the board and even tell us here's
what your lab report should say those of
you who didn't get these results you're
going to use these numbers and so what
lesson did we actually learn science is
made up that's not true but but that
would be you didn't learn that it failed
because I put in two grains too much of
this chemical well there must have been
some sort of error that we were making
some some minor thing but you know if we
were following the sort of scientific
mindset strictly we should have drawn
the conclusion that science only works
part of the time you know but we didn't
because
because a lot of it really is sort of
just sort of like you know what people
believe rather than what's been
demonstrated so if magic was going to
work the same way you know in a
different world you know maybe you could
snow people into thinking you're a great
sorcerer or something which is what they
do
mm-hmm you know it's no it definitely
doesn't you'd have to do some tricks
that actually work but you know Chalmers
and shade they're kind of to put them
you know not to want to think the kind
of [ __ ] artists in a way oh they
they they encounter these much tougher
magicians and they Bluff them until they
until they've actually acquired the
skills as the Connecticut Yankee well
that's true yeah yeah and he actually
tells them that he is doing magic mm-hmm
although if I had spent I haven't read
that book since I was a kid but he's a
real lover
doesn't he have like a cadre of young
guys who he brings up and teaches like
mechanical engineering and electricity
to that people who are in on that no
they were in the know about it what he's
doing
yeah I don't remember that do you
remember offhand yeah right there
there's nothing like that happening in
these one of the other things I didn't
want to talk about too as a
philosophical theme is the humor that's
involved in this it really is funny
stuff you know they're constantly
cracking jokes and the way the story is
told the narration is is humorous would
it be as good of a story if it wasn't or
with with the stories in general would
they be as good if they didn't have so
much goofing around and and wordplay and
if it was just straight serious stuff
you know what do you think if they
played over seriousness a little bit
more I think
and I wanted I prefer the yeah I think
it goes either either white depends on
the author and you know what they're
trying to do with the story some of the
serious place very well depending on how
it's written yeah other times the humor
is really if you do that if you do the
serious though isn't there more of a
risk of people like looking at the way
like how they got there or the way the
worlds are constructed saying this
really doesn't add up
except you know when you're reading it
in Spanish okay I mean you don't pick it
up thinking it's won't you do you don't
think about thinking there's other
projects book for physics for quantum
physics pick it up knowing that you're
reading fantasy so you automatically
suspend disbelief that's kind of an
interesting idea imagine another person
picked this up and they didn't know
let's say it was it was actually like in
the nonfiction section somebody was kind
of gullible when they pick it up and it
was it was written you know in a way
that's a little less dialogical oh yeah
yeah and it was written as it well there
were these people and they they figured
out how to get from one world to the
other and here's the theory behind it
and you know the first thing when Tintin
Norse mythology and these things happen
you know and that they they went to you
know the world of Spenser's Faerie
Queene which turns out to have been a
real world after all you know could a
person could a person read this and
think that these things actually did
happen I mean we're not we're doing that
a little bit in order to make the story
work right yeah I mean yeah you could
because there are plenty of people out
there writing writing that the Holocaust
never happened oh yeah true you know I
mean there are things out there
written that people buy into that
worldview there was a very interesting
exchange I saw on Twitter today and it
was by a guy who taught at a community
college and he was he was talking about
the fact that most of his students have
never heard of Dachau mm-hmm and he
started sort of exploring this is a you
know going like through a couple of
years he started exploring what it is
that the students come
some of them knowing and some of them
not knowing at all and how you know not
knowing certain things deprives you of a
frame of reference for that you need in
order to make sense of what's being
taught like he talks about another it
wasn't him it was somebody else
commenting on it talked about how a
student he asked in class and they were
discussing like the depression or
something and the student asked what's
the difference between Republicans and
Democrats because I don't know what the
difference is and the student literally
couldn't make sense they they're they're
struggling but they couldn't make sense
of a lot of the information that was
being given to them because they were
lacking that that background you know
there's a background like the politics
of the same sort of thing yeah I mean
well some of them would be political
right
well they darkly you'd also have to know
that what is now Republican used to be
democratic well sure yeah there are some
switches secret ourselves we're
Democrats yeah and then it switched yeah
it flipped and if you don't know that
history and I know plenty of people who
are out there on Facebook and stuff oh
yeah who really don't know that history
you don't you know they call their
cultural literacy event that's and it's
it's sort of like having like a
constellation of things
well I took Graduate School Business
I had lots of students who had no idea
we had a recession ladies
yeah that would that would surprise me
who I know cuz my dad about the
recession is though yeah informs
financial decisions today if you if you
know about it if you don't know what
happened and you don't know why it
happened or the various variables that
contributed to it you can make decisions
today yeah well I know that's a good one
too anyways in history that doesn't just
have to do with say economic history but
also with political history history you
know what's going on in the culture you
know yeah so there's all sorts of things
like that I guess actually you you you
know that's an interesting question how
much cultural literacy would you need in
order to make them a set of stories like
this really work work for you you know
can you read this if you don't know
anything about Norse mythology and come
away from it with with a decent-enough
story I mean when you've got like a
movie it's fairly easy because you know
get visual images right so gay guys are
fighting with swords or something right
that's not that hard to relate to you
may not know why the hell they're
fighting it was a good guy Norse
mythology if they defined it easier is
like gods yeah Giants or if you don't
know what a giant is a tall person like
yeah they're here yeah you know though
with some of this though so gods right
that would be that would be tough to
wrap their head around for quite a few
people in our culture who like say grew
up in a very conservative Christian
household where there's no plural gods
heresy you know yeah I mean I mean
in place like that if the reference any
sort of Old Testament is true the others
have taken God's other people at least
in the past worship other guys yeah yeah
yeah okay well them that with that that
wouldn't work that yeah but I do think
you have especially I think for it to
make sense so you do have never a
certain level of cultural literacy
literacy yeah I mean so emotionally
you're going from world to world to
world to know the difference between you
know the difference between them yeah I
mean a good a good storyteller is giving
you some of the reference points that
you need not just by referring to them
but by explaining them you know you have
the characters oh what's what's that
about you know then they explained it in
dialogue right and even schlocky TV
shows do that you know my wife likes to
watch Criminal Minds and we joke around
about it because boy is it is it you
know the writing is just so
straightforward in your face you know
exactly what's her to again at each
point right how it really works
yeah well I mean you know you you you
have these implausible discussions
between FBI profilers where they're
basically telling each other about
profiling works whatever Billy you know
what this sign indicates and stuff like
that which would never happen I think in
real life maybe if they're talking with
somebody who doesn't understand the
stuff it would but it's a great
narrative technique you know spring to
comp and Fletcher Pratt using it quite a
bit adherence I'm just thinking if you
didn't have a certain level of cultural
literacy with the cop yeah when you
shift the world no they don't do a lot
of explaining yes we get into the story
some of these are kind of obscured - I
mean Norse mythology is probably more
accessible more widely excessive
I would say then you know Edmund
Spenser's Faerie Queene III yeah I'll
tell you I've read The Faerie Queene
I've never read Orlando Furioso I was
there London 3 Oh says the one that I
drew a blank on okay
very clean even though it may not be
Edmund Spenser's Faerie Queene the world
of fairy exists in multiple yeah
multiple genres of fantasy well I mean
just with it with free oh so just think
okay there's magic involved there's lots
of nights
lots of flowery language and you know
it's very you know sort of high shovelry
okay Camelot Camelot no beyond that you
know I almost have noxious Lisa fun
finish ethology would be pretty obscure
for most people oh you know at the time
even more so I mean I think the literate
public of the 40s and 50s okay they
probably wouldn't know quite a bit about
Norse Norse mythology about Spencer
about you know Coleridge Orlando Furioso
they probably would know a little bit
about Irish I only be not anything about
theatre stuff we should de a lot of
people don't have no idea about Irish
mythology yeah yeah yeah so I guess that
yeah you see finishing mm so let's go
all right well this one particularly is
the Kalevala
okay but I would think very few people
who have any familiarity not at that
time and even now even now yeah probably
a little bit more now than then but it's
not it's not something that we're seeing
references to in our pop culture the way
we are with scene
really the only thing in here though
that we have any is an awesomesauce yeah
that's also because of Thor and Loki
mm-hmm you know the Marvel stuff we
didn't have a we have a few Viking
oriented movies come out but there's
really almost nothing in it about you
know Norse religion involved but I can
think of so yeah we have some Greek with
the Percy Jackson movies to be true yeah
yeah that's interesting because we
making questions yeah yeah and I was the
kid I was yelling who you know read
Greek mythology and then get kind of
snotty with everybody about well they
screwed up this part of the story and
this part of the story and this part of
the story and now I you know I want past
that but my own kids are doing that with
with these cuz they run the Greek
mythology and they don't like it when
they're playing too fast and loose but I
mean you know think about it you can't
make it good you can't make a good story
where it's just telling the same stuff
as the old stories right you've got to
have a bit more play in it which is what
they're doing here you know you get to
see that that I'm dollars you know
pretty cool guy and Thor you know he's
okay
you know very strong Loki you know and
you get to see him a certain respect
well so they have Odin in there and I'm
leaving but you know you could see them
in a different light than you went from
the old stories that's kind of an
interesting place to leave off to you
know is it is it good is it better to
like bring in you know these somebody
else's already fabricated stories as
your background or is it better to
create something totally new you know
where are they both perfectly legitimate
strategies for from writing sci-fi or
fantasy you know I mean if I want to set
stuff in a Star Trek universe people
been doing that for a long time now we
call that fan fiction right but maybe
I'm holding myself back if I do that
well things like the Star Trek universe
at least when Gene Roddenberry was
around yeah they try to keep he kept it
yeah okay he kept it bringing in in
terms of Spock would only act this way
yeah Kirk would only do these kinds of
things yeah you couldn't stray too far
from the basic model yeah yeah and you
could do that but you could enforce that
by whether you endorsed it or not you
know I mean now with fan fiction on the
internet though anybody could write
anything they want yeah so maybe that's
a little bit different though than you
know classical mythology and literature
I think so that too I was thinking you
know they talk about how far can they
strain yeah I think so it depends on
what you know about the author in their
process for example Diana Gabaldon who
writes the Outlander series yeah if you
know about her in her process you know
that she does a huge about historical
research okay
before she likes so there is some
confidence and we paper on the readers
part that the history is pretty close
okay it may not be perfectly accurate
yeah yeah and she may know she's not
just playing fast she made she may
switch a little bit of it out to make
the storyline work yeah but you can
pretty much assume that the basic
history is pretty solid around her
characters okay like the Barrett Battle
of Saratoga and things like that that
she's done at home
it doesn't write it without doing our
homework if you know that about the
author then you know what you're looking
at what if they're playing more fast and
loose like these guys well if you know
about the author then you know that
that's what's happening okay but I don't
know the very many people pay that much
attention yeah you would have to that
you'd actually have to know a lot of her
to catch you'd have to have an
understanding of the author's process
yeah I think the at least I used to be a
lot more from Star Wars
couldn't there a lot that you use
because that's all they had at the time
and then when Disney bought it and can
90% of the 95-99 yeah for good reason in
my opinion yeah I mean like
inconsistencies like yeah yeah he'll
over the place yeah but it's interesting
because now like they have like the big
things that like the biggest it's like
to cry out those overs like the throne
on trilogy and stuff like that so
they're they're bringing in little bits
of that and some of the older public
stuff but like it's still like one
percent to ninety nine but the fact that
there's any sort of makes it all is
unexpected in hmm yeah I suppose once
once you've done that it's pretty hard
to to reincorporate it right mm-hmm
because every time you do people are
gonna be like all of it but they should
do this listen listen this as well you
know that's kind of that's an
interesting issue what we don't usually
you know we're all they talking about
novels but but what goes on if you think
about how how fast things can change
and you know franchises like like Star
Wars right where you've got movies
coming out every so often we got a huge
mass of fanfiction people are writing
some of which may catch on most of which
have probably hardly anybody reads you
know other than the author and their
friends and then you've got cartoons
right what else going on novels right
great in graphic novels
I mean servers was beset with a problem
even from the start because splinter the
mind's eye which I read when it first
came out I loved I thought it was a
great boy
Alan did foster wrote a movie was
commissioned and there was talk for a
while that would be where the series was
going and then it went the other way
so that that book just became kind of
like a war for me okay right meaning
nothing you know what can you do with it
ed by the end of it you know Darth
Vader's head is an arm cut off he's
thrown down a pit you know Luke and Leia
end up like I think they were like
kissing by the end of it if I remember
right they're not brother and sister so
you know so far from from what you could
have done with you know but it was a
full book it was a nominal you know by a
big-name science fiction author at the
time yeah and well that's actually the
good place to bring things to a close
though
so when Pratt died they had some plans
for more collaboration they're into
Persian mythology and legend never came
off unfortunately and so the series just
ends abruptly decamp tried to make it
work with some other guys other younger
science fiction authors but you could
never find somebody to collaborate with
the way that he did with Pratt and in
these stories so this is all we're going
to get but I mean if you think about it
as
this could have been a franchise right
because you couldn't up world after
world after world after world bringing
in like one new character maybe every
two novels or something they could have
milked this forever
you could have kind of gotten like a
Mystery Science Theater by words like
they're visiting all these different
that's yeah that's a great way to think
about it they could have like set like
almost like a cyclopædia Islands who
should we go after this time but it's
okay and it makes sense
yeah I guess that's the sort of that's
the screwball part right you know
everything about what Mel Brooks does
with his historical movies you don't go
to any of them for history of course no
but they're pretty they're pretty funny
you know I don't know how well they
stand up now I haven't looked at him for
a while maybe some of the jokes are
quite it's good to say they used to be
well we should probably bring this to a
close
yeah they're very over time so thanks
for a great discussion again and
next time is under Norton and which
world for the first three novels of that
series lot of fun
[Music]